let's go next to um why don't we go
there's just so many people interested
in getting on today
it's hard to know where to go why don't
we go to luke from minnesota next luke
you're on the air uh hello
so i was wondering what you would think
of a potential boycott of the 2020
olympics in uh
uh china you mean the 2022 olympics in
china yes 2022 yes
yeah we we talked about this on the
bonus show earlier this week
there's three types of boycotts that you
can do there can be a diplomatic boycott
where the athletes go
but the country doesn't send
representatives it's sort of like a
diplomatic protest
you can do an athletic boycott where you
don't the country doesn't send any
athletes and then you can also do what's
called the boycott light which is
diplomats and athletes go but the
diplomats
make statements that are critical of of
the government
um i i tend to think that i want the
athletes
there and we've had so many examples of
conflict between countries during which
athletes still went
and i don't particularly care about the
olympics but i think it's
a good message to say that the athletic
community is going to
compete in a way that is not tied to
politics
and let the diplomats do what they want
so if they want to do a diplomatic
boycott
okay if they want to do boycott light
but i would definitely send send the
athletes
all right thank you so much that was a
very good answer all right thank you
very much yeah that's
we'll talk more about that i think as we
get uh
closer to that point in time